the Joe Rogan experience yeah I think I
see what you're saying and I think what
they think is you have to silence these
bad voices like the anti-vaccine you got
a silence and deeper sort of taking
anti-vaccine they're taking ante vac
spaces down you know I don't know how
much they actually know about the
science you know I don't I mean vaccines
are incredible for health in terms of
what they've done to protect us from
disease they've stopped smallpox they've
stopped polio and when you see these
outbreaks of measles that is a direct
result of people not getting vaccinated
you know does that mean that no one's
ever been hurt by vaccines no no it
doesn't man there's a vaccine court
people been injured people have died
that's a fact but that's I think just a
part of medical procedures and human
beings meant a lot of kids die every
year from circumcision yeah they get
infections they lose their penises yeah
yeah it's like very common like way more
common in terms of like the numbers per
year than you would ever want to hear Oh
God
okay people die from things they get
infections people get have allergic
reactions to certain chemical but then
this problem is now those vaccines can
say we're being covered up yeah now
they're honest it's the truth they are
being covered and are being covered up
yeah so it's very it's a I think a
problem is who's right and who's wrong
like if if you're a person and you have
a child and you're terrified can you go
to these websites like oh my god I don't
want my kid to get autism like but
they're saying that vaccines cause
autism
I'm not vaccinating my kid I'm not gonna
take the chance and that's where a lot
of it comes in yeah if you watch those
videos and you watch a video that's not
done by a scientist that's not up to
date on what we know about what cause
like I had Peter Hotez on who's very
knowledgeable about vaccines and very
knowledgeable about diseases in general
and he was describing the the what they
think the causes of autism are that how
it takes place in the womb and how
what's most likely happening is it's
just expressing itself at the same time
that the kids getting vaccinated and
you're correlating the two things
together